Now, next question, will Republicans consider
Biden illegitimate for four years?
Yeah, I think that this is sort of a good
question to be asking the questions about
will Biden really be sworn in?
Seem like a waste of time.
The questions about can Donald Trump really
do this, that that that that, you know, all
of these six, seven, eight different things
that he's floated or others have floated as
ways to maybe steal the election.
We mentioned some of them earlier lawsuits
or seizing voting machines, having governors
send different electors.
All that's none of that stuff is going to
happen.
I think the right question is how corrosive
is Donald Trump insisting on this stuff to
democracy and in particular, the way in which
Donald Trump maybe never conceding and insisting
he actually won, will affect the Republican
Party through Joe Biden's first two years
and.
Four years in the Oval Office now, I think
there's two sides of it.
One is how will it affect Republican officials?
And the second part is how will it affect
Republican voters?
Let's do voters first, because I think that
one's really easy.
I think it's very clear at this point that
the combination of Trump insisting it was
I mean, just listen to the voicemails I get.
People are convinced, Trump insisting he really
won combined with Newsmax and 081 and, you
know, of the different the different hosts
and characters that have been insisting Trump
actually won.
That will leave a significant portion of the
75 million who voted for Trump, believing
Joe Biden is an illegitimate president for
the duration of Joe Biden's term.
There's no question about that.
One is easy for me.
The voters have been affected.
Many believe Trump one, etc..
Full stop.
The more interesting question in terms of
Biden's governance, because Biden can't really
do anything about millions of Republicans
thinking he's an illegitimate president.
The real question is about Biden's governance
and will Republican elected officials, Republicans
in the Senate, Republicans in the House of
Representatives and Republican governors around
the country, will they in some way resist
working with Biden in any way, specifically
by by failing him to recognize failing to
recognize him as a legitimate president?
And I think it comes down to how visible Trump
will be after January 20th if we've already
seen more and more Republicans just say Biden
one.
Mitch McConnell even congratulated Biden last
week.
We covered that.
Trump was very triggered by it.
If Donald Trump just sort of evaporates politically,
fades away on January 20th or before or slightly
after, I think you will see the vast majority
of Republicans go back to dealing with Joe
Biden the way they dealt with Barack Obama,
which is there will be some who said Barack
Obama wasn't really born here and isn't a
legitimate president.
But for the most part, they did the normal
Republican things obstruct, pretend to be
worried about the debt and deficit, call things
government takeovers.
Any time the Democratic president wants to
do something, I think that's what you will
see most Republicans go back to you.
Now, the difference is there are some really
wacky Congress people elect ready to be sworn
in the House of Representatives in just days.
And I think that regardless of what Trump
does, there's there's Kuhnen people who are
entering Congress.
You know, you have to understand the impact
of that.
I think they will continue to say they're
absolutely wacky stuff for for the duration
of their terms.
And hopefully they will be so ostracized by
left and right that they will lose in twenty,
twenty two.
That would be the hope.
It may not happen.
We may see more kuhnen stuff in twenty, twenty
two.
I just don't know yet.
So that that's basically the lay of the land.
I think that what Trump has done has irreversibly
put millions of his supporters in the mindset
that Biden is not legitimate.
I'm hearing from them in my voicemail every
single week.
But the real question in terms of Biden for
governance is how will Republican senators
and members of Congress consider him?
And I think for the most part, they will see
him as the legitimate president.